.
>> A ME CHOICE.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> SO, A THAT WAS A BIG NIGHT
NOT BECAUSE CAT FINAL A FINISHED
HER SNOOPY JIGSAW PUZZLE.
A LITTLE PERSEVERANCE CAN
PAYOFF.
THAT WENT OVER WELL.
ALL RIGHT.
BUT ALSO THE ELECTION FOR THE
LATEST ELECTION COUNT LET'S GO
TO OUR MAP.
SORRY ABOUT THAT.
LET'S GO TO THE REAL MAP.
THAT'S NOT WRONG IT'S JUST
INCOMPLETE HERE'S THE ACTUAL MAL
MAP NO FRAUD IN THAT ONE FOR
SURE.
LIKE THEY SAY VIRGINIA IS FOR
LOVERS.
WHAT AN AMAZING MESSAGE SENT BY
AMERICAN VOTERS.
PARENTS HAVE HAD ENOUGH OF
DESTRUCTIVE RACIST WOKISM, THE
IDEOLOGICAL ROBOTIC BRAINWASH
FORCED IN ALL FACETS OF THEIR
LIVES, NOT TO MENTION TERRY - -
ROBOTIC DANCING.
>> THANK YOU, GOD BLESS YOU AND
LET'S GO OUT AND IN FORCE.
M'MM.
MY GOD.
SOMEONE PLEASE CHECK TERRY'S
MEDICATIONS.
HE HAS MOVES LIKE JAGGER, IF
MICK WERE HAVING A SERIES OF
STROKES.
IT MAKES AL GORE LOOK LIKE
JENNIFER LOPEZ.
EXCEPT INSTEAD OF HAVING A BIG
ASS HE IS ONE.
I HAVEN'T SEEN DANCE MOVES LIKE
THIS SINCE CAT DROPPED A LID
JOINT ON HER OWN LAP.
THANKFULLY PARENTS WERE
BASICALLY THE OPPOSITE OF BRIAN
STELTZER AT A CAFE, THEY WERE
PEOPLE WHO HAD ENOUGH.
THEY WERE LIKE HARRISON FORD IN
THE MOVIE WIT, A COP UNDERCOVER
AS A PACIFIST AMISH FARMER ONLY
TO BE TAUNTED REPEATLY BY A GUY
WHO GOES ONE STEP TOO FAR.
>> AWWW... YOU'RE MAKING A
MISTAKE.
>> BOO.
>> HEY.
>> I LOVE THAT SCENE.
THAT WAS AMERICA DOING THE
PUNCHING AND THAT GUY BEING
PUNCHED, EVERYTHING WOKE THAT'S
BEEN SHOVED DOWN OUR THROATS.
MY FAVORITE PART OF LAST NIGHT
OTHER THAN THE MAGIC MUSHROOMS
AND THE MERLOT, THE JOY FROM
WATCHING THAT INCOHERENT WORD
REGURGITATER OVER AT MSNBC
COLLAPSE INTO A HEAP OF
NONSENSICAL VERBAL PUKE.
>> HE DID NOT - - I MEAN, HE Y
WORSHIPED AT THE ALTAR OF DONALD
TRUMP ON FOX NEWS.
HE FLEW IN INSURRECTIONS IN HIS
RALLIES.
HE SIMPLY DIDN'T - - HE PLAYED
DUMB ABOUT A ZOOM RALLY.
HE DID NOT REALLY PUT MUCH DYSEN
BETWEEN HIMSELF AND DONALD TRUMP
ON THE BIG LIE, OR THE DEADLY
INSURRECTION IN WHICH POLICE
OFFICERS WERE MAIMED BY FLAG
POLES.
I THINK THAT THE REAL OMINOUS
THING IS THAT CRITICAL RACE
THEORY, WHICH ISN'T REAL, TURNED
THE SUBURBS 15 POINTS.
>> OH, WOW.
CRT ISN'T REAL.
AND WEAPONS OF MASS DESTRUCTION
WAS.
HOW GLORIOUS WAS THAT IMPLOSION?
IT WAS LIKE WATCHING MICHAEL
JACKSON SET HIS OWN HAIR ON
FIRE.
INSURRECTION FLAGS, FOE SUCH
THING AS CRT, SHE'S BLURTING OUT
TALKING POINTS LIKE A
MALFUNCTIONING STEPFORD WIFE.
IF SHE GOT ANYMORE MISERABLE
SHE'D BE THESE LOW-BRAINED DIP
ODDS.
>> THIS IS NOW ALL FROM THE
REPUBLICAN PLAYBOOK IS IS TO USE
THESE ISSUES TO SCARE PEOPLE OF
FEELING OUT OF CONTROL, THAT
EVERYTHING'S OUT OF CONTROL WITH
THEIR CHILDREN AND THEY NEED TO
BE PROTECTED FROM THESE PEOPLE
WITH THE DEMO GOSHES AND THIS
AGENDA.
>> SURE.
>> IT'S ARE BE CLEAR, SOME OF IT
WAS DOG WHISTLE., RIGHT?  SOME
OF IT WAS DOG WHISTLE RACISM.
>> A THOUSAND PERCENT.
>> IT TOOK HER TWO TIMES TO
FIGURE IT OUT.
SO WHAT HAPPENED TO THESE TWO?
I MEAN MIGHT BE BREAK DANCING
BUT THESE PEOPLE ARE BROKEN.
POWERS IS TRYING TO SELL A BOOK
CALLED GRACE WHILE SHE SELLS
LIES ABOUT RACE.
SHE REALLY SHOULD GET RID OF THE
G IN THE TITLE IF SHE'S THOUGHT
DESPERATE FOR FOR RELEVANCE.
STICK TO WHAT YOU DO BEST,
EATING INSECTS.
>> ARE YOU READY?
>> CHEERS.
>> I'M LIKE SCARED OF THIS.
OKAY.
>> SHE WENT FROM EATING CICADAS
TO EATING CROW.
AT THIS RATE SHE'LL BE EATING
OUT OF BRIAN SOCIALER'S GARBAGE
CAN.
THAT'S NOT EUPHEMISM.
IF YOU WIN IT'S ABOUT RACISM, IF
YOU LOSE IT'S ABOUT RACISM, AND
FOR CN INTHEY DENY THAT THEIR
OBVIOUS WITTER LOATHING FROM
MOST OF AMERICA SPELLS THEIR
DOOM.
DON'T FEEL BAD FOR THESE LOSERS,
THEY RELIED ON SEX PESTS SCUM
QUATS AT THE LINCOLN PROJECT FOR
COMMENTARY WHOSE HOPES OF
DISPLAYING PARENTS AS RACISTS
BLEW UP IN THEIR FACES AND
THEY'RE NOW THE ONES IN
SOOT-COVERED BLACK FACE.
THE ONLY EXPERTISE LINCOLN
PROJECT HAS IS KNOWING THE BEST
PLACE TO WATCH BOYS SOCCER
PRACTICE.
FLUSH.
SPEAKING OF PERV ENABLERS, WHERE
IS RICK WILSON OR JOHN WEAVER OR
STEVE SCHMIDT SOME.
BOY, DID THEY GO SILENT?
THEY'RE AS DONE AS A BAG OF
MICROWAVE POPCORN COOKED ON HIGH
AND THEY DESERVE IT.
AFTER CREATING THAT TIKI TOO.
HOAX DESTROYING THE LIVES OF A
FEW STUPID DEMOCRAT OPERATIVES
THEY SHOULD BE SHUNNED FOR LIFE.
TO CALL THEM SCUM IS AN INSULT
TO EVERYTHING CURRENTLY LIVING
ON THE RIM OF A PUBLIC TOILET.
NO OFFENSE, ANDREW CUOMO.
YOU KEEP HEARING THE PHRASE BELL
WEATHER THE SELECTION OF A
CANARY IN A COAL MINE.
WE WERE CHIRPING TO ANYONE WHO
LISTENED THAT WOKISM WAS RACISM
IN DRAG AND WOULD ULTIMATELY
DRAG THE TERRIFIED DEMOCRATS
INTO THE ABYSS.
THE DEEMS DON'T WATCH THIS SHOW.
IF THEY DID THEY COULD HAVE SEEN
THIS COMING.
NOW THEY'RE AS SCREWED AS A
12-DOLLAR HOOKER LEAVING
HUNTER'S ROOM AT THE MOTEL 6.
[APPLAUSE]
>> WHY DO CHEAP HOOKER LINES
ALWAYS WORK?
INSTEAD THEY LISTENED TO THE
CLUELESS CREEPS AT CN AND MSNBC
AND NOW YOU SEE THOSE DOPES
FINALLY COMING TO GRIPS WITH
THEIR OWN DOPEYNESS.
THEIR DUMBY COME LATELIES.
>> YOU KNOW THE DEBATE AMONG
DEMOCRATS TOMORROW IS GONNA BE
THE SAME DEBATE THAT HAS BEEN
HAD NOW FOR TREVOR, THE LIBERAL
WING IS GONNA SAY YOU'LL SEE
WHAT HAPPENS WHEN WE BACK TRACK
FROM OUR PRINCIPLES AND THE ARE
GOING TO SAY IT'S TOO FAR TO THE
LEFT.
>> IT'S A TEDIOUS DEBATE.
>> THE DEMOCRATS ARE GONNA HAVE
TO COME FACE TO FACE WITH THIS
ISSUE OF WOKE.
>> YOU HAVE A LOT OF PEOPLE
SAYING HE WON BASED ON SOMETHING
THAT'S NOT REAL.
THAT DOESN'T EXIST.
CRT OR WOKISM, WHATEVER YOU WANT
TO CALL IT, I AM TELLING YOU, I
MEAN, THAT'S ALL FAIR AND SOFT.
>> HM.
WELL, THEIR STORY CHANGED FASTER
THAN BIDEN IN A VATICAN BATHROOM
AFTER HIS LITTLE ACCIDENT.
THAT IS A RUMOR THAT HE POOPED
HIMSELF.
PROBABLY DIDN'T HAPPEN BUT THE
JOKE STILL WORKS.
IT'S FUNNY IF WE HAD SAID ANY OF
THAT THREE WEEKS AGO THOSE CHUMS
WOULD HAVE CALLED US RACIST BUT
NOW THEY KNOW THEY'VE BEEN ON
THE WALK HORSE, OR SHOULD I SAY
HORSE'S ASS.
AT THIS RATE THEY'LL BE
APPROACHING REALITY IN 2024 WHEN
BARRON TRUMP FINISHES HIS SECOND
TERM.
LET'S SALUTE A REAL
GROUNDBREAKER - - THE FIRST
WOMAN ON CURL TO WIN A VIRGINIA
STATEWIDE ELECTION AND SHE DID
IT AS A REPUBLICAN.
>> I'M TELLING YOU THAT WHAT YOU
ARE LOOKING AT IS THE AMERICAN
DREAM.
THE AMERICAN DREAM.
I AM NOT EVEN FIRST GENERATION
AMERICAN.
WHEN I JOINED THE MARINE CORPS I
WAS STILL A JAMAICAN.
BUT THIS COUNTRY HAD DONE SO
MUCH FOR ME I WAS WILLING,
WILLING TO DIE FOR THIS COUNTRY.
U-S-A [CROWD CHANTING U-S-A]
>> JAMAICAN ME HOT.
I DON'T KNOW WHY I SAID THAT.
ANYWAY, SHE IS LIVING PROOF, BUT
YOU DIDN'T HEAR ABOUT IT ON THE
VIEW, ON CNN, OR MSNBC, AND WHY
WOULD IT BE BECAUSE SHE'S A
REPUBLICAN?  THAT'S HALF OF IT.
THE OTHER HALF, SHE WAS BLACK.
THE FACT IS THE TRUE RACISTS
PREFER THEIR PEOPLE OF COLOR TO
FOLLOW ONE SET OF BELIEFS.
YOU LEAVE THAT PLANTATION AND
YOU'RE DEAD TO THEIR MASTERS ON
CAGE NEWS, WHICH IS THE REAL
STORY OF THIS ELECTION.
IT EXPOSED WHO THE REAL RACISTS
ARE, AND AS PREDICTING HERE ON
MONDAY, LAST NIGHT THEY GOT
THEIR TIKI TORCHES SHOVED RIGHT
UP THEIR BUTTS.
LET'S WELCOME TONIGHT'S GUESTS.
HE'S A KILLER COMEDIAN,
LITERALLY HE MOVED TO ALASKA AND
KILLED HIS CAREER, COMEDIAN
WRITER AND ACTOR JAMIE LISSOW.
THE ONLY BEARD IN HIS LIFE IS
THE BEARD ON HIS FACE, OUTSPOKEN
EDITOR AND CHIEF OF CONTRIBUTING
EDITOR TO THE SPECTATOR,
CHADWICK MOORE.
HE'S CONQUER BOOKS, TV, AND
PODCASTS AND NEXT YEAR HE TAKES
ON PUBERTY.
THE GUY BENSON SHOW HOST AND
FOX'S CONTRIBUTOR, GUY BENSON.
AND SHE'S LIKE A REMOTE.
HARD TO OPERATE, TOO MANY
BUTTONS, AND YOU KEEP FINDING
HER UNDER THE COUCH, FOX'S
CONTRIBUTOR, KAT TIMPF.
JIM Y HOW'S IT GOING?
>> GREAT.
>> HOW'S ALASKA?
>> ALASKA'S GREAT.
IT'S GETTING DARK RIGHT NOW.
IT'S DARK.
THAT'S WHERE YOU SEE MOVIES
WHERE IT'S DARK 24 HOURS A DAY
AND ALL THAT STUFF AND IT'S
AWFUL.
AND PEOPLE GO ISN'T IT
BEAUTIFUL?
I GO, I DON'T KNOW, IT'S DARK.
>> HAS IT CHANGED YOU AT ALL?
>> I THINK IT HAS CHANGED ME.
I FEEL LIKE I'M A LITTLE BIT
TOUGHER.
>> YES.
>> I'M A LITTLE BIT TOUGHER.
>> HOW SO?
>> JUST - - WELL, CAN I BRING
THIS BACK TO SEARS?
>> YES.
>> OKAY.
DID YOU SEE THE PICTURE OF HER
ON INSTAGRAM?
>> WITH THAT MACHINE GUN?
>> THE MACHINE GUN.
>> WON YO WHAT IT WAS.
>> IT WAS A GUN WE DON'T KNOW.
BUT I SAW THAT - - I DON'T KNOW
IF THESE GUYS SAW IT BUT I SAW
THIS PICTURE OF SEARS HOLDING
THIS MACHINE GUN AK-47 LIKE I
CAN'T WAIT FOR THE NEW TARANTNIO
MOVIE TO COME OUT.
EVERYONE MAKES EXCUSES BUT THE
REASON THINGS ARE TURNING THE
WAY THEY ARE IS PEOPLE ARE TIRED
OF EVERYTHING; RIGHT THE.
WE'RE TIRED OF ALL THIS STUFF.
THANKS FOR THE ONE CLAP
[APPLAUSE]
NO.
I HONESTLY THOUGHT IT ONLY
DESERVED ONE.
BUT BECAUSE THE PRO IF TO CALLS
RUINED EVERYTHING.
YOU KNOW IT RUINED COMEDY.
AND EVEN WHEN WE HAD SHOWS THEY
WERE WE.
I WENT TO A SHOW ONCE AND THE
PERFORMER ON STAGE WORE A MASK
THE ENTIRE TIME HE WAS ON STAGE.
AND IT JUST KIND OF RUIN IT.
HE WAS A VENTRILOQUIST, OR WAS
HE?
>> THAT WAS TWO-PARTER.
>> YEAH.
SINCE I MOVED TO ALASKA, I GOT
ALL TWO-PARTERS.
>> YOU GOT A LOT OF TIME IN THE
DARK.
>> YEAH.
>> YES.
SO, GUY, UH, WHAT - - DO YOU
THINK THE DEMOCRATS LEARNED ANY
LESSONS FROM YOUR KEEN MIND?
>> I THINK SOME OF THEM WHO ARE
MORE RATIONAL AND INTERESTED IN
WINNING MIGHT LEARN SOME LESSONS
BUT THEIR BASE, RIGHT THE
ACTIVIST CLASS ON TWITTER, THE
PEOPLE ON MSNBC AND CNN THEY ARE
DOUBLING AND TRIPLING DOWN ON
CALLING EVERYONE STUPID,
IGNORANT, MANIPULATED BY
MISINFORMATION, AND RACISTS.
>> RIGHT.
>> AND IT WORKED OUT SO WELL FOR
THEM LAST NIGHT I HOPE THEY GO
WITH THAT FOR THE NEXT YEAR.
>> YEAH.
>> I WOULD WELCOME THAT.
I ACTUALLY LIVED IN VIRGINIA, I
VOTED EXCITEDLY FOR THIS TICKET,
REPUBLICANS HAVE NOT WON ANY
STATEWIDE RACES FOR 12 YEARS IN
VIRGINIA THAN THEY SWEPT LAST
NIGHT.
I WILL SAY TO YOUR MONOLOGUE, I
DIDN'T THINK GLEN YOUNKIN HAD
THIS IN HIM HE'S THIS EARNEST
SUBURBAN DAD IN HIS VEST.
HE SAID, I READ THIS TODAY, HE
SENT A FRUIT BASKET AND THANK
YOU NOTE TO THE LINCOLN PROJECT.
IT WAS A TROLL OF THE TROLLS AND
I APPLAUD HIM.
THAT IS A GOOD MOVE.
>> GOSH KNOWS WHAT'S THEY DID TO
THAT BRUTE.
I CAN THING THINK OF A FEW
THINGS.
CHADWICK HOW ARE YOU?
>> I'M GREAT, SIR, HOW ARE YOU
NONE I AM FANTASTIC.
>> GREAT.
>> WHAT DID YOU THINK OF LAST
NIGHT?
>> WHAT IS AN INSURRECTION OF
SLAG?  IF AMERICA, WE'RE TOLD
AMERICA IS SUCH A HATEFUL RACIST
AWFUL COUNTRY, SO RACIST YOU'VE
GOT TO SEND YOUR RACISM IN MORSE
CODE APPARENTSLY APPARENTLY WITH
THESE DOG WHISTLES.
MY MY BIG TAKE WAS THIS WAS NOT
A REFERENDUM ON CRITICAL RACE
THEORY.
I DON'T THINK SUSIE JENK STILL
EVEN KNOWS WHAT IT IS.
I THINK AND THE REASON WHY THE
LIBERAL MEDIA IS FOCUSING ON
THAT IS BECAUSE IT WAS ACTUALLY
ON COVID, COVID MANDATES, COVID
PANICS, ESPECIALLY WHERE IT
RELATES TO THE SCHOOLS AND A
BUNCH OF PARENTS WERE PISSED OFF
THAT THEIR KIDS WERE HOME FOR A
YEAR AND WANTED REVENGE.
THE MASKING OF THE KIDS, THE
MANDATES, ALL THAT.
I DON'T THINK CNN CAN TALK ABOUT
THAT - -
>> THE KIDS IT'S SO REAL.
>> IT IS INTERESTING, KAT, ALL
OF THESE THINGS KIND OF CAME
TOGETHER AND IT SEEMS LIKE THE
DEEMS WERE ON THE WRONG SIDE OF
EVERYTHING BUT THEY CAN'T ADMIT
IT.
>> I'M NOT GONE SAY THAT TELLING
PARENTS THEY SHOULD NOT RAISE
THEIR KIDS ANDS SHOULD BE
GOVERNMENT INDOCTRINATION CAMPS
HAD NOTHING TO DO WITH IT.
THE EXIT POLLS, ECONOMY WAS THE
TOP ISSUE, THE GALLOP SAID
52 PERCENT, THINK THAT,
GOVERNMENT'S DOING TOO MUCH.
SO IT'S PRETTY CLEAR PEOPLE WANT
SMALLER GOVERNMENT SO OF COURSE
THEY'RE GONNA KEEP LOSING IF
WHAT THEY LOOK AT AND THEY SEE
WELL, OBVIOUSLY IT'S BECAUSE
THEY WERE BEING RACIST AND
AMERICA'S MOSTLY RACIST, IT'S
HARD TO, I DON'T KNOW IF THEY
ACTUALLY THINK THAT OR NOT
BECAUSE THERE'S NO EVIDENCE OF
THAT.
>> YEAH.
I THINK IT'S, I THINK WHAT
HAPPENS IS IT IS NOW JUST
DOCTRINE AND THEY HAVE TO, THEY
CAN'T LET GO OF IT.
IT'S PART OF THEIR SYSTEM AND
IT'S GOING TO RUIN THE PARTY
UNLESS SOMEBODY PULLS THE PLUG.
I THIN